MAN, I JUST WENT THROUGH MY
FIRST WINTER HERE IN NEW YORK.
A LITTLE COLD FOR MY TASTE.
BUT FINALLY IT'S STARTING TO
WARM UP, YES.
YES.
[APPLAUSE]
ONLY TWO MONTHS UNTIL THE CITY
STARTS TO SMELL LIKE A HOT
DIAPER, CANNOT WAIT.
CANNOT WAIT.
[LAUGHTER]
FINALLY MAN TRYING TO GET OUT OF
MY UGGS.
[LAUGHTER]
AND GET INTO MY OTHER UGGS.
YEP.
IT'S WARMING UP FOLKS.
THAT MEANS TONIGHT TALKING ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE.
YEP, THAT'S HOW I DO IT.
SCIENCE.
YESTERDAY COLD, TODAY WARM.
CLIMATE CHANGES.
NOW A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T LIKE
TO TALK ABOUT THIS.
THEY'RE VERY UNCOMFORTABLE BUT
IT'S MUY IMPORTANTE.
AND WE NEED TO HAVE AN HONEST
CONVERSATION.
WE NEED TO KEEP THIS A
HUNDRED DEGREES. AND WHERE
BETTER THAN TO TALK ABOUT THIS
THAN LEVEL HEADED FLORIDA.
>> THE STATE EPA BANNED
THE EMPLOYEES FROM USING THE
TERM CLIMATE CHANGE OR GLOBAL
WARMING.
THIS WENT INTO EFFECT AFTER
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR RICK SCOTT
TOOK OFFICE.
>> Larry: SO THE FLORIDA
DEPARTMENT OF ENVIRONMENT
PROTECTION CAN'T USE THE WORDS
CLIMATE CHANGE.
THAT'S LIKE TELLING RUDY
GIULIANI HE CAN'T USE 911.
IT'S NOT FAIR.
[APPLAUSE]
THAT'S ALL I'M SAYING.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THE TERM
CLIMATE CHANGE. THEY CAN'T
THINK IT'S ONE OF THOSE CRAZY
LEFT WING TERMS LIKE HEALTHCARE,
RIGHT.
I DON'T THINK THE LEFT HAD
ANYTHING TO DO WITH IT.
>> IN 2002 FRANK LUTZ ADVISED
REPUBLICANS AND THEN PRESIDENT
GEORGE W. BUSH TO JUST STOP
TALKING ABOUT GLOBAL WARMING
BECAUSE IT'S SCARY
AND START USING A LESS
SCARY PHRASE, CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> Larry: SO REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR RICK SCOTT IS BANNING
THE TERM CLIMATE CHANGE WHICH IS
THE TERM REPUBLICANS CAME UP
WITH TO BAN THE TERM GLOBAL
WARMING.
BECAUSE OVER TIME CLIMATE CHANGE
CAME TO MEAN WHAT GLOBAL WARMING
MEANT.
CAN'T WE JUST BAN THE TERM RICK
SCOTT?
[APPLAUSE]
I MEAN, IT WOULD JUST BE CLEANER
ALL RIGHT. HOLD ON NOW.
IT'S NOT REALLY JUST A
RIGHT-LEFT ISSUE, THOUGH.
IT SEEMS LIKE EVERYBODY WANTS TO
CONTROL LANGUAGE THESE DAYS.
>> FACEBOOK EXECUTIVE SHERYL
SANDBERG HAS STARTED A CAMPAIGN
TO STOP USING THE WORD BOSSY
WHEN TALKING TO GIRLS AND YOUNG
WOMEN.
THE ARGUMENT IS IT HINDERS THEM
ON THE PATH TO LEADERSHIP.
>> JUST BAN THE WORD BOSSY.
BE BRAVE, BE YOU.
BAN BOSSY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Larry: I DON'T KNOW IF I
WOULD YELL THROUGH A MEGAPHONE
TO TELL PEOPLE NOT TO SAY
BOSSY.
[LAUGHTER]
MUDDY'S UP THE MESSAGE.
BUT I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING. IF YOU CALL A GIRL
BOSSY IT'S LIKE SHE'S BEING
PENALIZED FOR BEING ASSERTIVE
AND SO IT'S AN INSULT. I DON'T
KNOW IF WE NEED TO BAN THE WORD
WE JUST NEED TO TELL PEOPLE TO
STOP INSULTING WOMEN. JUST A
THOUGHT
[APPLAUSE]
BUT I GET IT.
I GET IT.
I COMPLETELY GET IT.
EVERY GROUP HAS THEIR TRIGGER
WORD.
RIGHT FOR BLACK PEOPLE IT'S THE
N WORD, FOR JEWISH PEOPLE IT'S
THE K MAKER, FOR PUERTO RICANS
IT'S BEING CALLED DOMINICAN.
EVERYBODY HAS THERE THING.
BUT UNIVERSITIES  HAVE THEIR
SENSITIVITY TURNED UP TO 11.
>> AT THE UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN
HOPED STUDENTS WILL STOP SAYING
CERTAIN WORDS AND PHRASES THAT
CAN BE CONSIDERED OFFENSIVE.
SUCH AS ALIEN, ILLEGAL, GHETTO
AND GYP
>> Larry: REALLY, THESE ARE
YOUR WORDS? YOU'RE TAKING AWAY
ALL MY PARTS OF SPEECH
IF AN ILLEGAL ALIEN GYPS ME IN A
GHETTO HOW AM I SUPPOSED TO
CONSTRUCT A SENTENCE TO REPORT
THAT? I'M SCREWED
OK, WELL WHAT'S WRONG WITH
ILLEGAL ALIENS.
>> "ILLEGAL ALIEN" IS SAID TO
SUPPORT THE BELIEF THAT
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS ARE LESS
THAN HUMAN.
>> Larry: HOLD ON.
I ALWAYS THINK OF ALIENS AS MORE
THAN HUMAN.
THEY FLY AROUND IN SPACESHIPS.
THEY CAN COMMUNICATE
TELEPATHICALLY, THEY BELIEVE IN
THE PRIME DIRECTIVE.
THEY DID KIDNAP SKULLY BUT OTHER
THAN THAT,
THEY'RE PRETTY BADASS
YOU KNOW WHAT? IF THESE ARE THE
WORDS YOU CHOSE TO GET RID OF
ON YOUR CAMPUS, YOU HAVEN'T
HEARD BAD WORDS YET.
LET ME TAKE YOU GUYS TO
KNOWLEDGE COLLEGE FOR A QUICK
ONE, ALL RIGHT.
PUTTING MY SMART PATCHES ON.
OOPS, THAT ONE FELL OFF.
THAT'S A DUMB PATCH.
PROFESSOR NIGHTLY'S IN THE
BUILDING.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
NOW LISTEN UNIVERSITIES.
DO YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT BAD
WORDS SOUND LIKE.
I HAD MY STAFF COME UP WITH THE
LIST OF THE WORST SLURS WHILE I
STEPPED OUT TO MAKE MYSELF AN
ARNOLD PALMER.
THIS IS WHAT THEY CAME UP IN
FOUR AND-A-HALF MINUTES.
WOW, I'M BASICALLY NEVER LEAVING
ANY ROOM MY STAFF IS IN AGAIN
I DON'T TRUST THOSE GUYS AT ALL.
THIS IS WHAT THEY TALK ABOUT
WHEN I'M NOT THERE?
I DON'T WANT TO BE CALLED ANY OF
THIS STUFF.
OK, THIS SOUNDS HORRIBLE BUT DO
WE HAVE TO BAN DUNE COON?
I JUST LITERALLY NEVER HEARD OF
IT BEFORE AND NOW YOU'RE TAKING
IT'S SUCH A TIGHT SLUR, YOU GUYS
KIND OF LIKE A HAIKU.
IT'S JUST SO MUCH HATE IN SUCH A
LITTLE SPACE
AND IT SLAMS TWO GROUPS AT ONCE.
I MEAN I HATE ITS HATE BUT YOU
GOT TO ADMIRE ITS EFFICIENCY.
IT'S THE FORD FIESTA OF RACIAL
SLURS, THAT'S
ALL I'M SAYING
KNOWLEDGE, YOU SEE.
THE OTHER WORD.
ALL RIGHT.
K COLLEGE IS OUT.